Hey. What you Mr Tom Evans and you worked as a rigger for Dorman long on the bridge.
Didn't you do you remember being signed up for the job to a member getting the job.
Well not a Met particular occasion but while Boss was Jimmy Moore and I happened to get in touch with him and.
I got the job right away. Painter same and.
So where did you start first of all well then you got me bait there now it's a long while ago.
But it's been a few years though back going back into it.
So you wouldn't expect a man to remember it or would you know not what do you remember where you started
and what you did I remember.
Then in charge of the paint is on the approach bands where we started out and they are a man at sight of a chap.
That was on the north side that a year to be a bit of a smart alec and you remember
when the trams were running across a jumped over the rail in front the tram got killed.
You know what his name was I never can never remember it and I. But I was the first remained.
To ever start the painters are on the approach planes and that took a lot of doing I don't mind telling you.
Because I don't suppose they'd ever been up any more than about forty feet on a lather. And.
It was quite a job to get them used to everything.
I stand on the bridge in different parts and explain all the scenery around the place to hear them.
And then I put them in a very strange chair and put a slipknot on them or something. If that was the case.
They were going to lower themselves down.
Well all that had to be gone through because they were new they only thing they had was ladders
and paint brushes the scrapers would say for argument's sake.
So they had never painted chips or certain anything big like that they'd never been well reluctantly spake
and they'd never been up and the higher than the lather where put it that way but they were well
and chaps they were good body a man.
Well I suppose they were all nationalities
and you had to agree with a lot of them that they did now understand that kind of work you know what I mean.
But needed to say they shouldn't have been on the bridge in the first place
and workers should have been doing their job because an ironworker is a would be doing chip and scraping and painting.
And my going to good job of it. But painters and themselves they don't use years of paint scraper.
And then dab the red lead on and go with the paint. But all in all there were.
It was a pretty exciting job and a good job.
You had everybody is why I've tried to get in to do and things on a job like that.
But Sanders you had the know how it more or less went along with them and just show them what was what.
What did you do after the approach spans.
Well they approached that well all night job on the approach by
and she was the same thing is way down on the outs which when dad from the seventh panel.
So they ate panel is that right. The panel do the thing on it all together.
And I had the same petition patients and their own all they hang is.
The cause and the roadway underneath the roadway on top.
No matter where you look I was there but did you work on the on the arch with the painters
or were you working as a director or rigging right through the whole thing
and regards to any particular job that was going.
Besides paint is in that there was other jobs to do such as stage work and.
Well whatever it is a part of the job you had and we had to be recognized.
Whether it be in a Saemon but I did understand it that way. Lots of nuts and supplies just a bit down and.
Stages to be built and what have you and who was it who was there to do it on the people that were capable of doing it.
And did you work on the erection of the arch a toll on me while it was under construction on the whole thing right
through round the doors point and including the approach
and chair they are going out from the Dawes point side to the middle
and well do you remember exactly how they went about correcting the should self the panels the procedure.
The whole thing you'd like me to tell you the Anchorage. Well they are just just the just the rigors job.
The point of view of erecting from the rigors point of view.
Well the rigorous point of view was that they had to go to anything that had to be down.
They had to make the anchors for that bridge to go out in the first place. And you know the doors point then.
Where the main span the. A lot going on that doors point and at one particular time was an old gun mounting place.
Well they had to make an angry each there to hold that bridge up even on the north shore side they had to do the same
thing.
They'd done on the South Side that was they get a proper length and the anchorage was down about thirty to forty feet.
And that was dug out of saying the stone and the same stone at all. Recesses OK I understand.
Parts going from one side they are there where that the wires were in laid in that particular angry
and the very thing that just went up to about supports that held the bridge in the first place.
Otherwise the damned thing would have collapsed
and it might have it just like put new broom in trying to stand a broom up in the middle of the floor and fall over.
Wouldn't it.
That Were you involved with the tunnels the increased tunnels at all how that was all done by a library like people
that worked on the masonry and that.
You might find a few other fellows that worked on the masonry did you hear say found were people who work on the
masonry just said you know they named it all.
Harry Harry Powell I think it is I'm not quite sure he was one of them but we got a few of the most alive
but what I particular want to know was what was your job on the actual you know.
If if you were involved with the picture show to appear a little in the cradle.
Well we're going up to an erection constructional cry out that they were the constructional crowd
and you weren't with them.
Partly at times with them but not all looked on my mind ya been looking out the paint is doing all their stage work.
And then as you might know it is on the chairs for crying is that right.
This take trains on each side on the no doors point side and on the. Note shore side.
Well then we had a big stage went down and ate the roadway remember that one. And then we had.
Stages going along the pedestrians for so all in all there were mechanical things that were put out there
but then there was a lot of rope stages
and different stages had to be put up in the know all that you had to be versatile with all ours kind of things.
To remember any accidents on the bridge. Do I remember them. Well remember Kelly as I mentioned a while back that.
Kelly one day drop this banner in the harbor
and it turned around said to May are supposed to man to be going over there.
One of these days like the Spanish don't be damn silly.
Well it wasn't long after I had telly fell off the desk into a walk.
And what do or can I say any more than hit the water with a splash and he sent his prior up about ninety eight.
Did you see him at or. Now just heard of him coming out.
And he swam from where he fell into the punt where Faulkner and others that were dog went down Main.
Sam were going to dive in and poke Cally a out but he swam that to the bide.
And they managed to pull him on to the barge.
And then they only thing about that Faulkner that was killed and mentioned what I know about the the plight.
But will you just tell us tell us a story of how fault and was killed. Yes such what I'm doing now.
Now as they approach as the chords went out. They had strengthen and plates on both sides.
And they used about each section. They played about it onto each section.
To strengthen the bridge as it went there because it had to have all that support.
Otherwise it would have collapsed because it was only held up by nuts and bolts and rivets.
But what was happening up on the top of that cord I can't realize or say
but I have some mentorship ation that they were trying to put a shackle in that plate
and lower it down with the crying and down below Faulkner we're sitting on a gurney straddle legged dog with this guy.
And there's the plight came down so he was dogging it in between go down to the pond collect them on the harbor
and somehow or another.
There's plight got out of control and it came down like a snake
and hit all of Ridgeway that's the hangers on the way down.
And came down and struck crush Faulkner's family artery and the leg was hanging Loesch.
And I was the first one to get over the riot and the leg and steady him he was quite conscious the whole time.
Well of bursting out down. We couldn't get a tonic eye on each leg but I for a stretch. Oh.
Well we got him on the stretcher assistance of others.
Give me a hand to lift him over the rail on the roadway and we took him to lift.
We had a lip at the back a divorce point and but we band when we got into the lift.
We couldn't get the stretcher and it was too long.
Then we took him up on the big crane on that with a small crane in front of it.
We took him up with a small crane and then way back a whole lot down to the dollars point
and where we lowered the book and I down with the crime
and then transshipped him from that crane to working steam cry and it was on the dollars point
and from then our I remember it was one of his mates ran to him.
And that was that it took him to sit in the hospital but I think he died out too. It's about three o'clock.
I mean out the moon.
You know that's all I know in regards to poor old Faulkner Yes here is Thomas three a clock in the afternoon seems to
be correct version from the from the morgue records as well though. It's a funny thing about Mrs Faulkner.
I remember coming down whether it was that day or days afterwards. With a baby and their arms.
Now mind you have a good memory to think of all this. Regards the baby been in Mrs Ball in his arms.
But I never had a chance to speak to her but I know she spoke to several other workers.
And it's a peculiar thing I go to Reagan jobber C.S.R.
Roads and like all time you march stand and have a bit of a yarn while you were able.
And a young fellow came along with a part of paint and a brush in his hand. This is twenty years afterwards or more.
I JUST BECAUSE THEY COULD I was a child hand that particular time.
And as you came up and approached is and got near it as I said to him I was what your name.
Is my name is Potter ISIS book no aces Yes. I said Joe Pa they get killed on the Harbor Bridge.
He says Yes well I said I'm one of the men that went to your father's assistance and that's that. If you get me here.
Thank you very much to member any other accidents.
Yes I do remember one very bad action there was a fellow named Campbell Jimmy Campbell.
Well Jimmy was it an Englishman. And his quiet versatile regular.
And quite a decent kind of a fellow and quite conscientious every time he was doing a job.
Well he worked per the masonry that was going up most of the time during stage work and that
and as that stage work went out.
And the stone work went out the years a lot of acid because lending it down
but make the preparations for cleaning the list down work down.
Campbell had to put some girders show the port Howards if you remember on the top of the pile and.
And it put a stake up there.
I can give you the length of the stake somewhere about ten twelve foot and they had bog guy on that stake.
They were going down the road wage where they were angry. But whatever happened regardless of this action.
I don't know whether one of the guys became loose all the way in got them to that.
Why that more or less push they go over an angle.
I'm not precisely clear about really what happened
but I don't know what happened to the steak that Campbell was putting out.
It fell over the top with a masonry
and of Jimmy Campbell had to run the way the stick was falling he would have been all right.
But he ran back the opposite way and got underneath right
and ball to do him over the break wary hit the stonework on the wide and just missed and the electrician work
and on the hangers it you know is where that train is run across. Now. Pardon me body when he power.
All wriggly inside underneath the roadway and Bell and other hundred or so odd plate down below.
But what happened with regard to the Reminds of Jimmy had a big claim down up the stonework and my boss Jimmy Muir.
Said to me she was going to do about it.
Well I said went out to put a tackle up there and send a man up to clean it down.
So I say let me get a bottle of whisky and give that chap a drink and eyes who are left to lash him in the chair
and take him up so that we're down and then he went out and he done the job but
when he finished the job I said to Jimmy Muir you can't do it. Use that rope any more fires that are.
Well I said it's probably part of acid and I say for years that again.
Sam be the one that's going to have a now and next and with that. Well as you what we're going to do about it.
Well I say the best thing we could do is get some kerosene and put it over the rope
and set fire to it so that was another job that I remember very well
but that's as far as I'm concerned with Jimmy Campbell
and if one of those things that was a sad turn out to find a man like him.
There is he's lived as he did but when you come to look at things in the rigging game.
That's at thing you take on yourself but you must. Be a bit of a contortionist at all. Con. And a bad.
Walk across it is no matter what the dimensions are that is so what's it going to take it in your own hands.
What you're about to do but if you're conscientious and you can do that class of work.
Well walking on God is just as good as walking on the ground down below it didn't make any difference if that was your
job and you had to do it. So that's there. Thank you very much for telling us about that.
Do you remember any amusing incidents that happened on the bridge to put on a lighter vein.
Well nothing like well line that we had an amusing kind of cartoonish there and a puddle Adra another from the roadway.
And they approached by and they had.
Every cell going out there
or somebody else a new ISP ain't been splattered all over the place I remember that as a matter of fact I've got that
photograph here but I don't know where it is just the moment. Now I can't think of any.
Oh yes I do they only thing I remember that could be comical atmosphere.
Where is when the great went across the bridge. But unfortunately though.
We were in the procession that day we went from dollars point across the North Sydney.
But you could just imagine where most of us spend each step.
We've been used up in the past but that incident with the group. Well.
Jacked language than mine man to cut that bridge and the. As you head the story or read the story.
The degree got in first.
But I'm sorry for what happened to him Now you got a good kick in the backside and hold up the horse and.
What happened there. After that I don't remember but.
I never same the incident but what I heard about it is wiped out of what I'm telling you. And.
Can do you remember any other particular things about the bridge you remember the way it was remember the conditions to
member the union thing about. The way the working conditions were competitors I do.
Regards regards the bridge in that respect.
Our money on the approach Bandra six pound a week and now a high money and then when we got out on the bridge.
It was seven pounds a week and now hide money.
So you took your life in their hand whether or not for that screw that we got but I suppose they are just the same
when you come to look at it now that money was small with no money.
Something that you had to be thankful for that you had a job to do that.
No I can't think of anything more than that
but the main table that got paid for their work was a crane drivers they got bought in pound a week so I don't know any
more than. Do you remember the on workers me Union in those days. It's true.
As I was the Member for that as a matter of Baghdad. An appointed delegate in parts of it.
And still holding my own job was to charge him.
But oh yes I think more or less through all my regen profession was still an hour
and work till I went in the gas company where I was a regular still and.
A lot of highs today over there in those gas howlers where I worked around the circumference of them
and never had any hand rails a row to hang on to it just walked around as they are walking on the footpath.
But there were difficult problems in regards to that particular job.
Yes I suppose all in all no matter where I've been a monkey.
But often I was told I had now tiled But I spoke of other privileges in life was my apprenticeship to see.
And then they carry on until they either came and I would say MN. Where you had to save your apprenticeship.
I think that had a lot to do with my climbing. But I have very much.
Regrets as far as my knees are concerned and I think all that climbing has got a lot to do with what.
Pains and aches that I have with them.
Tell me when do you go to sea
when you were very young boy we do the first ward only for the night in right through the first four years.
Yes I was an old condors transport. Crosas of thank goodness.
Part of the whole lot of it like to mention from time to time.
And we were in the navy your merchant ships well then you combine the two I was in Bahrain.
The Navy and the merchant navy. Were you born in Australia now that I was not narrow.
I bet you couldn't tell me where I belong to. Were you able to tell me now now now.
An Irishman born the place called Dublin. And I've been doubling up ever since.
That's all I could tell you in that part but when did you come to Australia.
Well though I came back with the last lot of numeric Caledonian.
And we show a New Zealand dish
and the last bunch of astrologers as far as I can remember that was in nineteen nineteen.
Well between now and in eighteen nineteen nineteen. Now.
Where did you work first were well the say and where they only played.
And so how did you come to get on the bridge when
when did you leave the C O O round of at twenty seven nine hundred twenty seven.
And I think that was around about the time I think that I. Now I think I went out on it went out in the country then.
Belling now is Bob and concrete silos and oh I forget now just when I came back.
And it was then long before I went on the bridge again. But.
Do you remember what happened to you when you finished on the bridge.
Did you get a job straightaway Oh we had to work on it all now there you've come to a particular question
and a very awkward thing it was the thing that while I was on the bridge that one thing that I used to take now is of
no matter where I work. Odd always see a crowd of maimed and taken there.
But for the love of million of you more hate that thank God I didn't know what the hell a bloody dollar was
but they tell me they were all that was out of work and drawing there
but little did I ever know ever think that I was going to be on the go.
And then some happened while we were in the parade from Doris point. To the north side.
Now in a procession that bind all the people lined up along the route wouldn't do.
And I remember a few girls of many girls.
Saying
and out while we were walking in the procession he'll soon be on the dollar of my letter that I ever realized I was
ever going to be on to it but I don't know if it is the most main this thing ever.
I thought of was that old
and I tell you it was hard to find money to put in the blooming gas the to do a better cook and
and watch your dead get for cooking. Five bob awake and all the rest was in coupons was. All the rest was in coupon.
And then when I got my first young by the.
Party job to get milk for him
and the most you got the children in them days read about oh it's part of it by above a fortnight they would get much
more. But things resent a hell of a state. And paying their rent was one of the hardest jobs.
I remember one time they live in a residence and.
We couldn't afford to pay the rent and needed to say I was taken to court over it.
I suppose they would charge me at the back of my neck if they could.
But when I got to the place caught my eye and so the judge was poverty circumstances.
So I got another three months later of life and that's the only thing I remember about that
but the dough although But how did you pay your rent. You know if you had no money coming in.
You had only the only the coupons for you for your money. That's what I say you had to let the landlord go.
But so did you have a pain in the end. Well I don't ever remember paying it.
I think more or less the idea was I'm in a light which they call it.
But everybody on the dole couldn't have had any money to pay the rent. Oh well if you take things into consideration.
One of the worst thing is that I ever could remember and I just wanted. Out of the conditions I would live in and.
Often thought well there must be thousands like me you know what I mean. But one of the engines I remember.
I went down to Hoskins and stale that speech pay. Where I went down. There's a charge ten rigger also.
And I was on the building of a hundred seventy five ton crane down there.
But from that crane to other jobs that had to be done. Putting construction were sheds up and one thing in the other.
When I have they got what I wanted done. There was no further pity for you. There is close on about.
So YOU thousand workers put up the Clairton riggers and boilermakers and what have you. And back on the dollar again.
And why the thing used there was we had to write a pushbike those days and we went around the different shops.
Begging for a loaf of bread and sausages and.
Better state govt bound to some whatever good eight to try and achieve your purpose to live.
But it was a hell of a state of A and no one can believe at that particular time.
That desperation was at its lowest and you had a chart of those times with one or two children to do one child
and two children in a matter of fact. And it was quite a job to try and get different things. For those children.
Milt and different thing. One style went to K. Street. If you know where K. Street is there.
And I seen the specialist and he ordered three bottle of milk a week.
And when you went down to get the damn dowel all I give you would one bottle. So you could tell what sort of a fight.
I put out to get that tray bottle. As a matter of fact the Custom House whether that was a help the potman some of it.
I went in there and the question was asked what do you want to hear.
I want to say that help inspect the other doctor that helped our regard extra milk. And food for my child.
Oh I see you won't you can't saying well I shall not live in it like I do seem. He said You'll have to get out of it.
I'll get out. I'll get a place for you. Well I say go ahead go and get the place.
And I put the baby on the counter and I said you can look out there him now if you get the place.
So I needed to say I got a victory. I got three dollars remote back. And you had to fight for every bit you got.
Well I think it did because under the supervision. There was not much that you got out of life.
But the hardest part about it was I was quite a young conscientious fellow
and I would have done anything to get good to do any job that was going but no not in US way to life.
You couldn't even. I doubt very much. If you are allowed to hold of the pressure. If they could have stopped that.
Had done that. He had died of oxygen but needed to say. It was a pretty tough time right through.
So when you get the next job after the after that period of unemployment.
Well I think then while that while that procedure was going on being out of work.
Our live brand new town them die and I haven't met biting spirit to try
and get something I went down to the government to have some McQuarrie straight.
And I say in one of the women politicians down May and age. What do you want. I say I want to job.
Asian good and a man they want and Serge board and when I got down there was a bad two thousand blokes might for a job.
So there was no job there going. But one of the things I do want to say. As regards politicians.
We put in for extra money when we worked on the bridge and to get that money politicians were concerned.
And they had to come up on the bridge to find out what while I was getting extra money.
And how this is the funniest part about the story relating.
I don't think politicians it will cross that R.'s go it is not near as way to live. You know we had to do.
We had to go and build a wooden platform across the roadway. And they you know how they got out there bang.
Crawled out on all was made to say out the time we found we got it. Fifteen. Bob away gagged in a pie show ever.
The been a politician was asked to build the bridge. It wouldn't be built yet. RUSH.
Tell me do you remember seeing Bredfield or any sort any of the big wigs around.
Oh yes we used to have a bit of a young man again. Dr Bradbury was a little out of very high ball boy.
And is he would a very big man when I think one of the biggest med ever seen and I've seen the whole lot of them
but they used to go up and around today. Oh no. And it's had no fear.
It's only went wherever and the same way with what was the other bloke we mentioned the name just a while ago.
You know. Oh he'd go anywhere to read.
Do you remember the chief construction engineer Hipwell well very well yes yes do.
Matter of fact I've still got my old bad. Brass my dad and I you for your time.
Keep it up as you know what I mean it picked it up in the morning
and put it back on of a night time I've still got it here somewhere. I don't know where it is I'm at the fact.
Did you get the can but to puppet when the darts was joined now that's another question. I never thought of at bat.
We got eight Canberra Florence. But little did I know then.
Regardless they value of them to day invite in on the value of the die. Yeah there's still got my money's worth.
There where the thousand dollars.
I believe I'm a part sure about that
but you know the pay our hotel where we went over them which are the that alarms on the counter
and we drank beer for the strength of what they gave me I can bare floor and a bronze medallion a bronze medallion
and A Now Mo bad to wear in Abbottabad consisted of the word should me have a bridge page
and I've still got that as a matter of fact.
But one of the instances I tried to overcome which to try and get some souvenirs. And I lost a quid trying to get them.
And that was the train that came across the bridge.
I got the driver to slow down and I put the money on the Ryo so they get BLACK IN THE MONEY AT barmy.
But Natixis I add of a quid I only got two bob back. I intended to ours they cry and the engine driver's name.
And I've got all about it. But that was another instance.
But oh I've seen very funny things happen to remember them all.
Well that's why the thing to have done too bad so I have I done very well.
Do you remember a bloke known Bluey would had the name is merely a to me but there was a chap there French
and Froggy we used to call him did he have a mouthful of gold. Well then I can just go back on that time.
It's quite a you could have had them. But I know he was a bit of a monkey also those Frenchmen.
And I think if he can go back if he could remember
when there was a fire took place on the Harbor Bridge one of the stages went on fire.
They took the cooker they used to call them days where is the fellow that cooked the rivets
and I suppose he thought he put the fire out.
But when he knocked out that night better wind came up and start the fire going again.
So needless to say there was chain blocks on the stage and ropes and everything.
And the monkey went up when he tried to put it all out but at the time he got up there it all collapsed.
But one of the things about staging would lead to that particular incident do you remember a bloke named chair's HAYES
Well the night you mean rings a bell
but not to go back to their notes just where that particular incident of a fire hurt so that you supposed to go to the
fire brigade up there. Well now I don't know. Never in your head of a passport. Had it been a bit of a job wouldn't.
Take There might have been our getting a pump on the roadway
and pump the water out harbor if they could have got up at five.
But then again it would have had to have the road by laid down.
That one other thing huge Do you know about what the roadway belt of on the bridge. You don't know.
Well I know but the people. Other than no other new.
Well I was going to ask you the question in regards to what you thought of a Obs You know what I mean.
And whether it is stone of ash belts or well I thought it was concrete with ash felt on top. Well that's right.
It was laid out from the gas company but to lay it down with care and cement.
There was a lot of open ans on the channeling of the bridge there that had to be take the showers the concrete wouldn't
fall down over the paint. It's already been painted on the need.
And the respect to dollars from going on that anybody could give them an idea to stop that paint that can't create from
going down on the paint
and they are like to think what it was fifty dollars fifty quid just to put on the pallet is mentioned.
So you get a light canvas and tear strips and paint it with red LED which done the job.
And then the guy in Beijing know about the roadway rises arises.
Can you tell us about the road where exactly what is the principle of The Rise and Fall of the town.
Well there's no for the rising bar would have been bad one hundred forty feet that sound. All right.
Most people wouldn't think that they're when they're traveling back with employers across there.
I think it's paid would think it would be flat wouldn't I.
But you knew about all the locomotives they were put up there. Did you were.
Would you tell us about the day where they tested the bridge the day they put the roof.
Well then that they put about seventy two locomotives up there.
Somewhere about six they are seven hundred eighty town but they laid down there for about seven
or eight months before they took them out and that's inspired I know regards to testing.
And I think that's about all I can tell you about the testing. Crowd. Thank you very much Mr Evans.